okay everyone we're good to go now
before I start this particular idea
let's just get some context for where we
are in this topic okay areas on the
curves we started with this whole idea
of how do we get shapes right like this
and they don't fit all the normal kinds
of shapes that we know how to you know
get formulas for my company so how do we
get an area and we looked at all these
different ways of do it we looked at the
exact way in which we've called
integration right we recruited a couple
of not exact ways of approximate ways
what were they number one for
trapezoidal and Simpsons rule which I'll
buy like yeah so did I tell you this dad
taught you about why it's called
Simpsons rule so the first time it's
really tricky finding like attributing
stuff in maths because it's not like um
people don't invent stuff in maths you
discover something like there's a
relationship it always exists there and
we tend to name it after the first
person who recognized it right or if
it's got some other appropriate name you
know we don't call them Riemann's
like they start we call them rinses
anyway so um the first question we know
about who used the seasons rule rule
which was like you know put a parabola
was actually kepler who's kepler today
mom
decided to use a space guy is an
astronomer why is it called Kepler's
rule because Kepler was German and it's
not that we don't like Germans it's just
that English they just didn't know about
it it's been a Simpson with British okay
now we looked at those methods in
frustration then we saw that you can use
integration not just to work out areas
what else could you work down volumes
specifically what kind of volumes we
look at okay now at this point we've
learnt I think all of the theory you
need for this topic okay so all I'm
going after now is something the tricky
there kinds of concepts the side ideas
which you might mean a question and
having not had to explicitly explain to
you you might be like I don't know how
to do this at all and it's a trick that
you could do yourself honestly but I'm
just going to try and save you some time
now when you see the word evaluating
okay that should give you a clue what
kind of AG rules are we talking about it
only to which kind of my talking about
if I'm saying evaluating its own that
definite so I'm gonna give you a
definite integral right and I want you
to stare at it for a little while if you
can see how to work it out that's great
keep it to yourself for a second right
but for the rest of us let's try and
work out of this is equal to this okay
so you look at this question and
hopefully you scratch your head for a
second because of what kinds of
functions do we know how to integrate
well we know how to integrate just
regular old sort of polynomials right so
if I had said x squared yes no problem
power power up divided by the power or
fine okay
we know how to do stuff like say if I
gave you this it'd still be fine what
would you do that by the way what would
be your first step you could you could
go let u equal and then you would choose
something now I wonder if you've done
enough exercise of substitution you
start to get used to it gets quite
predictable right so some of you might
be at the point where you can say look I
don't need to do any substitutions here
I'm just gonna do this why would I do
that
yes so now this is in the form F dash on
F so you'd go straight here okay we're
getting there this comes in practice
okay if you couldn't see it immediately
no problems you were going to let u
equal and you're dutiful thing okay now
we've got a few other kinds of families
but this this is not one of them I told
you that the integration of log X is
possible once you if slash when you're
going integration by parts but I'm
telling you in advance I mean by the
fact that I've been giving you this
question you should know how to do a
question right now remember I've given
you the same right evaluated indirectly
okay so the direct way would be okay
think about what kind of primitive
function escape
right and then that'll be capital F you
got F of B minus F of a that's the
direct path for a definite interval
right but there's another way there's a
less direct okay what is it definite
integral about what does it mean where
did this topic start it started an area
right now help me out what does this
area that corresponds to this definite
integral what does it look like show
yourself up a set of axes now log X what
is log X look like how'd you describe it
it looks like that okay so it's that's
nice and close to the y-axis right it's
climbing but then it slows down and it
slows down forever okay so it gets
longer as long as long off but it does
keep growing it doesn't approach this
limit there's no asymptotes nothing like
that okay now we've got two we've got
one intercept here right what's the
intercept okay so log of one thank you
I've also got an asymptote here but it
turns out that for this definite e - I'm
not that interested one happens to be my
lower boundary okay I'm just interesting
a squared what's eating roughly 2.7 so E
Squared's somewhere between 8 and 9 I
guess okay so my scale is pretty awful
hopefully yours is a little more
accurate but just for the sake of
illustration I'm gonna pop a square
there okay make yours a little better
than mine oh yeah okay I guess it's but
anyway it's I'm just juicing this
ministration right so I've got an area
underneath okay so far so good now this
is sorta helpful at least I got a
picture in my head but now I come back
to my original question which is how do
I work at such an area okay now don't
actually say it but and I know I've told
some of you this story because if I ask
me some more questions like can any of
you without saying it see anything that
might be useful to us yeah anyone you
think you see something
got an idea why don't you shoot why
don't you shoot just and it so I heard
by the way this is really hard at number
one it's a it's a selective school thing
number two it's an asian-themed we hate
being wrong because it's like I don't
like being told that I'm I don't
personally don't like people at all but
being wrong is a crucial part of the
process of of maths science any field of
inquiry right because if you can never
get stuff wrong you're never gonna make
any progress in terms of like I don't
know what it is equal to it okay so we
got some doubted it's okay right well so
much for making some errors okay now can
you see what he's if you didn't catch
what he's talking about okay this is y
equals log X okay now it turns out that
I'm like I said integrating log X is
hard okay it's possible Behar however
log X is very much like another function
you know which is actually super easy to
integrate namely it's the inverse small
let me write it in Log form
this is log base e of X right
so to get its inverse you flip it you
reflect it across the line y equals x
okay so the graph you're going to get up
should put it in my color the graph
you're going to get looks like so
okay now it's going through you get the
idea okay now that's why it was either
yes right where is the area but I'll
show you like that where is its
corresponding section on y equals e to
the X well being that if you if you can
turn your head 45 degrees so you're
looking at it and that's vertical okay
if you flipped it directly across right
directly across that line here's what
you're gonna get some like this that's
the area right can you see the symmetry
yes
now that's one because e to the 0 is 1
and I guess this eastward up here should
go over here okay right now we're almost
there
we're almost there if this is e to the X
really easy to integrate all right but
if I integrate it with respect to X not
get this area because that's not the
x-axis right what area will I get the
other thing
more specifically areas under curves
right so I'm gonna get this area
underneath but as you can see that area
is just as good if I can work out this
area I can work out the other area by
subtraction just like we've been doing
volumes yeah okay so let's do it then
I'm gonna calculate the blue area by
calculating the green area by
calculating the red area all right sir
sorry wrong way the actual area of this
integral that I want right is Leslie
that's what I want
but it's equal to this rectangle - the
red area that okay that's how I get the
green area which is actually equal
so what's the area of the rectangle area
of a rectangle is length times or length
times breath or width or height which
everyone so the height here is a square
and the width is now to get up to the
squared
what am I gonna put in the answer is 2
right yeah this scale is terrible sorry
forgive me okay so my rectangle is 2
times e square that rectangle there now
I can subtract the red area the area
underneath the curve and I've got to
write a new definite integral for that
right what are its boundaries wasn't it
yeah that way okay the function that I'm
underneath is in the X and I'm bounded
to the x-axis all right we're almost
there
Chuey square the sorry - the primitive
function I mean DX is e DX we're still
away that's good from zero to two okay
go ahead and evaluate - e squared -
either the naught which is which is 1 so
that looks to me like double negative 1
okay so there's my final answer
this was the
which by the way I don't know about you
but what's really sauce
you're like 1/2 e squared and you get 1
plus B squared
what's up with that now I'm just gonna
let that rattle for a second it just
looks unusual that's the kind of things
that mathematicians look at and I think
something's going on there I should dig
at it but my point was the point was if
you get given a definite integral and
you need to evaluate it you can do it
directly if you like just find the
primitive tuck in the numbers off you go
ok we don't have to because the definite
interval is just a number
more specifically it's just an area
that's if you can work out an area
that's easier or more simple then you
might as well do it indirectly you'll
just get the same number out there now
we'll see if we remember kaleikini
no not a year's time maybe in seven or
eight months time when we have some time
if you want me to teach you integration
by parts we'll come back to this all
right and we integrate it and pop it the
arms the balance in and make sure when
we verify that we come back to this with
paper but that's pretty simple like we
can manage that right a tuna students
can manage that so keep it in your head
we'll be doing this kind of trick a lot
when we move on to inverse tree